[Music]
on this wednesday night inside an
overloaded and
understaffed intensive care unit
it's incredible how many younger people
were seen people who are healthy
variants pushing some hospitals to the
tipping point during this third wave
i haven't seen anything like this in my
entire career
ontario's new stay-at-home order what's
allowed and what's not
and some alberta politicians revolt
against new restrictions there
sidelined by covid we never would have
thought that
this would hit us like this what one
family has endured
and collision caused investigators
reveal why tiger woods
crashed his suv
global national with donna friesen
good evening and thanks for joining us
people across ontario are entering a
third state of emergency since the
pandemic began
and as of midnight tonight must observe
a strict stay-at-home order
for the next four weeks icu doctors say
it is long overdue and
the hesitation has led to more illness
and death more than 3
200 new covid cases were confirmed in
ontario today
17 more people died and for the second
day more than 500 people are in
intensive care
a record number we'll get to the
stay-at-home order in just a moment but
first we want to go beyond the numbers
and the politicians
to the life and death moments playing
out inside an intensive care unit right
now
the patients are young many got sick at
work
the doctors and nurses are exhausted
jeff semple
has our top story tonight this toronto
hospital
is jam-packed
that alarm ringing through the halls is
code blue
a man in his 40s just arrived with a
suspected case of covid19
and his heart stopped staff in the
emergency room inserted a ventilator
tube
and saved his life while other patients
are lined up in the hallway
just outside i haven't seen anything
like this in
in my entire career so far where we're
this full and we're anticipating to be
even more full
hospital staff are seeing firsthand what
those dangerous
contagious kovid 19 variants can do
it's hard i mean these variants of
concern are definitely
definitely changed the game and if you
walk the halls of the icu
you can see up close the changing face
of this pandemic we were here in the
first and second waves
where you largely saw elderly patients
sitting in these rooms but these days
there are a lot more people
who are younger it's hard to stomach
when you see young people that are
otherwise well
that you wouldn't expect to see this
sick most of the seriously sick in the
icu
are now under the age of 60 the youngest
just
21 and many here became sick
at work we are seeing that that a lot of
these people are in fact essential
workers
the risk facing frontline workers is
something leo jews family knows
all too well i'm really worried the
hospital's emergency ward manager
recently received news that his latest
covid 19 patient
was his own aunt to see my
personal family member going through
this covet
is a completely different experience it
was really scary
it's really high favor the 55 year old
nearly had to be intubated but is now
recovering
the massage therapist believes she
became infected
at work hospital staff are now calling
on the province to make essential
workers regardless of age
the top priority for vaccination grocery
stores the amazon
warehouse things like that are all front
line that get exposed to
to covet so i do think i think it's
important to realize that population is
at higher risk at this point this icu
doctor says the biggest challenge now
facing his team
isn't a shortage of beds but staff
13 months into the pandemic many of
their colleagues
have quit they couldn't handle it
anymore
we lost a lot of nurses in the past few
months
and it has brought a big
toll on us that we are left to to fight
this
and the result of that staff shortage
even some
available beds are now sitting empty
jeff semple global news toronto we want
you to hear another voice from an
intensive care
unit dr michael warner cares for
patients at michael garron hospital in
toronto
he's been using twitter to post updates
about what he is seeing
about the people who were dying his post
today is about how variants are killing
younger people and it's a call to action
for politicians
here it is i've been able to share some
patient stories which i think have been
helpful
in connecting the numbers to real lives
but some people do want numbers to
frame how they view this situation so
here are some from from critical care
services ontario
in wave one we lost a patient to cover
19 under the age of 50 in our isu's
every six days
in way of two we lost one every five
days in way three we're losing one every
two point eight days
at the end of wave two there were 44
patients with cover 19
in our isu's under the age of 50.
as of april 4th there were 68. i think
this trend is going to continue
because variant covet is a different
disease so what do we need to do how do
we not squander this stay at home
how do we make it worthwhile we need to
go after
cover 19 where it is and that's in
those high-risk postal codes it's in
those essential workplaces
we need to vaccinate those individuals
provide real workplace safety that's
enforceable
rapid tests and congregate work settings
pay people
not to go to work if they're feeling
unwell don't wait until they get covet
to give them two weeks off
unless we address the root cause these
four weeks or however long it will be
will be squandered
and more people will die thank you
ontario did announce today it will send
mobile vaccination units to high-risk
neighborhoods congregate
settings and large employers and that
everyone 18 years and older in those
places will be able to get vaccinated
it's part of a new approach from
ontario's premier who has been
under pressure for days to act i can't
stress this enough
things are extremely extremely serious
right now
and i'm extremely concerned
eric sorenson explains what the
stay-at-home order announced today means
and what it's hoped it will lead to
time is ticking down in ontario the last
day for non-essential shopping before
most doors are slammed shut
bought mamas and flowers oh that's nice
so we try to be productive
you can sense the dread again with a
lockdown
more than a lockdown a province wide
stay-at-home order
the reality is despite everything we've
done so far
the coveted 19 situation in ontario was
getting worse
high hopes for a normal spring have been
dashed by one simple dynamic covet
variants are spreading serious illness
faster than vaccines can be administered
to protect us
so the order across ontario stay home
except for getting groceries
prescription drugs or other essentials
or for medical appointments or exercise
with members of the same household
for businesses grocery stores and
pharmacies remain open
big box stores are limited to essential
items only
and non-essential retail can have
delivery and curbside pick up only till
9 pm
and then vaccines expanded programs for
lower age groups
high risk workplaces and certain postal
codes plus vaccines at more pharmacies
and mobile clinics in areas with high
covet numbers but most
schools outside the toronto area will
remain open
given that this is our best chance
to halt this disease to give us time to
vaccinate
why not pull out all the stops including
schools
in order to let that happen evidence of
the need the surge in hospitalizations
that have spiked today to almost
1400 approaching the peaks seen in
january
and numbers still rising for some the
province has responded too slowly to the
third wave
that's probably not a bad thing it
probably should have been province wide
much sooner
and it is a body blow to the mental
health of so many who've been locked
down for months
so i just been working i'm exhausted
katie bones is a private nurse
just coping it's all up in the air all
the time so frustrating
sick of it allison raines says it's hard
it's a long
game i definitely feel the strain on my
mental health
there is a lack of awareness of how
seriously mental health is affected says
one expert
i think people are overwhelmed with the
everyday life life something around 40
percent of the general population
is suffering from anxiety or depression
and now begins another month of anxiety
even children like isla have had enough
let me out till we've been in this
pandemic
for one year now can't just be cancelled
the pandemic cannot be canceled
and a stay-at-home order cannot be
postponed any longer
erik sorensen global news toronto
in alberta a caucus rebellion appears to
be brewing for premier jason kenney 15
mlas from the united conservative party
caucus including the speaker
are criticizing kenny's decision to put
in tighter public health restrictions
in a letter the group says it moves
alberta backwards
and is the wrong decision it says
constituents want them to defend their
livelihoods and freedoms as albertans
the new restrictions include shutting
down indoor dining in restaurants and
reducing retail capacity and stopping
group fitness
premier kenny says the measures are
designed to buy time to get more
albertans
vaccinated many alberta doctors say the
restrictions though don't go far enough
to reduce the stress on hospitals and
intensive care units
and they are calling for an even
stricter shutdown like the one imposed
last spring well we know younger people
are getting sicker and there is tragic
news out of quebec today
a 16 year old in montreal has died of
complications from covid19
hospital officials are releasing no
other details because of privacy rules
in a statement the hospital says people
who die at a young age from covid19
are generally people who had significant
underlying conditions
it's believed the teenager is the
youngest person to have died in
from covet in quebec the province
reported 1270 new cases today and eight
additional deaths global news has
learned canada's top spy the thesis
director david vino has
covet 19 now and is working from home
our ottawa bureau chief mercedes
stephenson has more on this
mercedes sources i guess telling global
news there have been a lot of concerns
about workplace safety
at csis that's right don assis
is the spy service responsible for
monitoring threats
to canada's national security and right
now
it requires all healthy employees to
work from the office
but multiple intelligence sources
approached global news to raise the
alarm
about some of what they say they're
seeing there the sources complained
about workplace safety
citing multiple covet 19 outbreaks at
the national headquarters in ottawa
and raising concerns about how physical
distancing is possible at full staffing
as well as concerns about mask wearing
and safety in the headquarters
in a statement ceases cited sensitive
intelligence work as the main reason why
there
isn't a work from home option for
canada's spies
saying given our unique mandate our
national headquarters
domestic regional offices and foreign
stations remain
operational during the kovit 19 pandemic
but some of canada's spies are
questioning that rationale
pointing out that similar agencies have
figured out secure
work from home setups including csec
canada signals an
agency the rcmp and the military
ceases confirmed that there have been
outbreaks in the headquarters
stating csis has experienced covid19
cases
including those linked to community
transmission as well as
limited and contained outbreaks global
news has also learned that
187 csis employees signed a mass
grievance over the agency's coveted
protocols and directives
complaining that they were potentially
unsafe and discriminatory
against single parents who are left
struggling to find child care when
schools are closed
and they have to come to work cesa says
they are committed to keeping canada
safe
as well as their employees but there
seems to be no plans ahead
to change the current policies donna
okay mercedes stevenson in ottawa thanks
it has been six weeks since the serious
crash sent tiger woods to the hospital
now police are revealing what caused it
that's coming up
[Music]
this buddhist monk in thailand has been
rescued from a flooded cave where he was
trapped for four days
the 46 year old was on a pilgrimage he
went inside the cave to meditate when a
rain storm hit
a team of 17 divers managed to reach him
today after a break in the rain
the monk was fitted with a mask and
guided out including
a 12 meter swim underwater to get to
safety
as more canadians get vaccinated there
are continuing questions about having to
wait up to
four months to get that second dose
rather than three to four weeks
canada's national advisory committee on
immunization said today it stands by its
recommendation
it extended the dosing interval in march
because vaccine supplies were limited
and they wanted to get some protection
to more people
faster now it says it has the data to
back that up
we looked at clinical trial evidence
that demonstrates very good vaccine
efficacy from the first dose
we also looked at new real world
evidence that suggests good vaccine
effectiveness
against symptomatic disease and
asymptomatic infection
a very good effectiveness against
hospitalization
nasi estimates 90 percent of adults aged
50 and older will get their first shot
by mid-june as will 75 percent of people
between the ages of 16 and 49
and they say as more vaccines arrive the
four-month interval
might shrink there is more information
tonight about the oxford astrazeneca
vaccine and those reports about rare
cases of blood clots
the eu's drug regulator has released the
findings of its investigation
it found a possible link between the
vaccine and the rare blood clots though
said
the benefits still outweigh the risks
several countries including canada
recommend younger people
avoid it and now british authorities
have released new guidance
too crystal gomencing explains the
findings
the demand for covid19 vaccines hasn't
changed
but rollouts are being adjusted now that
a link has been confirmed between the
oxford astrozenica jab
and very rare blood clots we are not
advising a stop
to any vaccination for any individual in
any age group
we are advising a preference for one
vaccine
over another vaccine the uk's expert
advisory panel says healthy people
under 30 should be offered an
alternative shot
if one is available at the end of march
79 reports of serious blood clots had
been recorded in the uk
with 19 fatalities that's after
20 million doses were administered from
these reports the risk of this type of
rare blood clot is about four people in
a million
who receive the vaccine
in those rare circumstances the oxford
astrazeneca shot seemed to trigger an
autoimmune response leading to
aggressive blood clots and in some cases
bleeding in the brain
the risks are very low but they exist
health canada adjusted the vaccine
labeling back in march
noting the rare events doctors say for
the vast majority the shot
is safe it's extremely important for
them to take the first
vaccine that's offered to them in canada
in europe
adverse reactions occurred more often in
women under the age of
60 but the experts who reviewed the data
say they can't pinpoint the problem to
any one group
no specific risk factors could be
identified
based on the current data the committee
can therefore
not recommend any specific measures to
reduce the risk
people are being encouraged to watch for
symptoms such as
chest pain odd bruising and swelling in
the legs
the blood clotting events occurred
within two weeks of vaccination
crystal glancing global news london
still ahead why a police informant is
suing the force he helped
[Music]
excessive speed has been revealed as the
cause of the crash that left
tiger woods recovering from serious
injuries california police say woods was
driving about 87 miles per hour when he
crashed and rolled his suv in february
the posted speed limit on that stretch
of the road is 45 miles an hour
the primary causal factor for this
traffic collision was driving at a speed
unsafe for the road conditions and the
inability to negotiate
the curve of the roadway police say
woods never applied the brakes they
believe he may have accidentally hit the
gas pedal
instead woods underwent significant
surgery on his right leg and ankle and
is
still recovering we're getting a rare
glimpse tonight into the shadowy world
of police informants
one such paid informant says he regrets
ever joining a police witness protection
program
and he is suing the rcmp and the federal
government as a result
ross lord reports for this long time
police informant the simple act of
breathing feels like a luxury
i'm still alive it's always a good thing
his birth name is paul derry he's a
career criminal who testified against
the hell's angels
for a murder in nova scotia helping send
this man and three others to prison
derry has had three name changes since
entering the rcmp's witness protection
program 20 years ago
he's suing the rcmp and the federal
government claiming they failed to
prepare
him and his family for living in witness
protection
i think the program to change i don't
ever want to see
a family have to go through what my
family's had to go through
[Music]
especially children the lawsuit claims
at no time did the rcmp advise paul
derry or his family
of potential mental health risks of
being an rcmp informant
it alleges his current wife has had a
mental breakdown
that his mother passed away without
anyone at rcmp telling him she was even
sick
and that one of his daughters thought
her father was dead for six months as a
teenager
before they entered witness protection
and that rcmp did not tell her
he was still alive she has not left her
house
for more than a few hours a month for
six years
she's petrified fear from the fact he's
still under threat from the hell's
angels
he says his children sleep in a separate
part of their house
for their own safety they know that if
anything ever happens that the dork
gets kicked in or they hear noise to go
to their mother and and get off
as far away from me as they can he and
other family members have received
psychological and addictions counseling
in a statement of defense
filed with the federal court of canada
the attorney general blames derry's
problems
on his own conduct and says it denies
any breach of contract
and further denies breaching any duty of
care the rcmp may have owed to the
plaintiffs the defense statement accuses
dairy of failing to acquire legitimate
occupational skills
and failing to cooperate with members of
the rcmp
in a statement to global news the rcmp
said it's made significant enhancements
to witness protection over the last five
years
and that the program has also invested
in additional staff
police officers familiar with witness
protection say the program's reputation
is important
because they need it to reassure people
it's okay to testify against
violent criminals witness protection is
one
uh tool that that we can use to try and
alleviate that
with the witnesses his hesitation
or fear really derry says he agrees
the last thing i want to see happen is
informants to stop working i just want
them to work under better conditions
and with more knowledge as to what
they're getting into
considering how his life has turned out
he says he might have been better off
keeping his mouth shut and going to
prison along with the men he implicated
at least then he says his sentence would
soon be over
ross lord global news halifax
next a family of nine's nightmare in
toronto after five of them get covered
we want to take you beyond the
statistics of this third wave tonight
and tell you the story of one family
first one of the daughters started
feeling sick then both her parents who
were teachers got sick too and then
two of her siblings almost the whole
family caught in the grip of the virus
karen lieberman spoke to them about
their ordeal
and what they want others to know
well i started feeling symptoms one of
my daughters started feeling symptoms
shmuley soroka and his wife are both
teachers in york region who fell
ill with covid19 as did three
of their seven children we have thank
god seven kids in different schools we
see how
what's going on in the various schools
and
and there's always risk one daughter was
exposed in the classroom to a variant of
concern and tested positive
it's believed she may have brought it
into the home where it spread quickly
thirty-nine-year-old mom alana who was
busy preparing for the jewish holiday of
passover
became the most sick it just started to
creep up on me that i was just sleeping
more and more and more
and and being able to do less and less
and less
she ended up in hospital severely
dehydrated with an infection and
pneumonia for five days
just a lot of fear of what was going to
be
and like leaving my family including her
youngest
just five months old we never would have
thought that
this would hit us like this in 24 hours
it just like came out of nowhere
pediatric infectious disease specialist
dr anna banerjee has advocated to keep
schools in ontario
open during the pandemic until now as
someone who understands the need of
keeping kids in school as much as
possible
i think there's a balance and i think
the scale is tipped
the sorokas are anxious to get better
and are encouraging everyone to get
vaccinated
if we vaccinate the teachers the
teachers are safer the um
the kids are safer families are safer
as alanna spends most of her time
bedridden recovering from covid19
shmuley has been busy caring for the
family he hopes this message gets out
we have a concept in judaism that call
yesterday
that every person is responsible for
another and we just need to
do our part to what we um do what we can
to
to keep each other safe karen lieberman
global news toronto
and that's global national for this
wednesday i'm donna friesen tonight's
york canada is the town of mono in south
central ontario
there are beautiful spots all over this
country please email us yours
to viewers at globalnational.com thanks
for watching hope to see you here again
tomorrow take care of yourselves
[Music]
[Applause]
bye
you